welcome to strategy across the board
a virtual gala showcasing the many ways
the st
louis chess club and hall of fame is
promoting chess as an art form
an educational tool our live program
from the st louis campus starts at the
top of the hour
with a special key note by world chess
champion grand master gary kasparov
until then please visit the virtual
rooms below for a look at the broad
scope of programs
offered by the st louis chess club and
world chess hall of fame
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health and strength
it's the sound of compassion of open
doors
where people and machines are in tune
and
miracles occur it's the sound of
personalized healthcare
and active communities it sounds like
life
and it's what you hear when you really
listen
thank you for joining us for the 2020
virtual gala
strategy across the board featuring
world champion grand master
gary kasparov our live program begins
shortly
we invite you to donate to the saint
louis chess club and world chess hall of
fame
in our efforts to advance the artistic
cultural
and educational benefits of chess
strategy across the board
is moments away thanks for being with us
that was an amazing piece of calculation
easily dominated his rivals when in game
after game the opposition has never been
as
heated as fiercely the most elite chess
tournaments in the world
hello i'm penny pennington i'm the
managing partner of edward jones
and our firm we have a simple and
important
purpose to make a meaningful difference
in the lives of
seven million clients and their families
our goal
is to help them to help you achieve your
most important goals one way that we
deliver on this is to help our clients
have a better understanding of their
finances
and investing our branch teams see
firsthand the confidence that can come
from a higher level
of financial knowledge after all the
best way to achieve your goals is to
understand
how the decisions that you make today
will make your goals a reality
in the future that's why we're making
tools like this
online financial fitness site available
to you
we recognize that many young people lack
the financial
information necessary to establish or to
strengthen your financial wellness
and we want to help we know from our
research that when you
understand the principles of finance and
investing
you're more likely to plan for the
future and to achieve
higher levels of education income
and career satisfaction these tools were
designed to be easy to use
interactive and to build financial
resiliency to help you be confident
about your financial decisions
no matter the market or the environment
we also created the site to meet you
where you are
so whether you use it at home or on the
go we hope you find this site engaging
and impactful
as you hone your knowledge and get more
financially fit
if there's anything that we can do for
you we have nineteen
000 financial advisors in all 50 states
in all 10 provinces in canada
and we're here to help you to answer
your financial questions
thank you for the opportunity to serve
you
professional golf returns to st louis in
2021 the ascension charity classic
presented by emerson
stars like phil mickelson ernie ells jim
furyk and more compete at norwood hills
country club
september 6 through the 12th tickets
clubhouse passes hospitality suites and
pro am foursomes are on sale now all
proceeds go to north st
louis county charities visit
ascensioncharityclassic.com or call
314-938-2828
pga tour golf is back in the loo the
ascension charity classic
welcome to strategy across the board a
virtual gala showcasing the many ways
the st louis chess club and hall of fame
is promoting chess as an art form an
educational tool
our live program from the st louis
campus starts at the top of the hour
with a special keynote by world chess
champion grand master gary kasparov
until then please visit the virtual
rooms below for a look at the broad
scope of programs
offered by the st louis chess club and
world chess hall of fame
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility will feature new
ground-level classrooms supporting
players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow even greater community
engagement
in the great game of chess as a proud
resident of the central west end
neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the sinkfield cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the us chess championships and
the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to children throughout
the st
louis area research shows children who
play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame
this one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors
to experience chess in imaginative ways
and is home to the us and world chess
halls of faith cutting edge exhibitions
feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art
innovative programming explores the
intersection of chess
art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries
and a premier gift shop highlight the
culture history
and creativity behind the game come
visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus
visit stlchestcampus.org
do
welcome to strategy across the board a
virtual gala showcasing the many ways
the st louis chess club and hall of fame
is promoting chess as an art form an
educational tool
our live program from the st louis
campus starts at the top of the hour
with a special keynote by world chess
champion
grand master gary kasparov until then
please visit the virtual rooms below for
a look at the broad scope of programs
offered by the st louis chess club and
world chess hall of fame
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health and strength
it's the sound of compassion of open
doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities it sounds like
life
and it's what you hear when you really
listen
welcome to strategy across the board a
virtual gala showcasing the many ways
the st louis chess club and hall of fame
is promoting chess
as an art form an educational tool our
live
program from the st louis campus starts
at the top of the hour
with a special keynote by world chess
champion grand master gary kasparov
until then please visit the virtual
rooms below for a look at the broad
scope of programs
offered by the st louis chess club and
world chess hall of fame
the prochest leak is an online chess
competition with teams that span
worldwide this season the st louis
archbishops won the league championship
for an incredible third time in four
years undefeated in their regular season
st louis beat india china and armenia
to cement the archbishops as a true
chess dynasty
we salute this year's all-star team
fabiano caruana
wesley so linear dominguez
and jeffrey zhang
thank you for joining us for the 2020
virtual gala
strategy across the board featuring
world champion
grand master gary kasparov our live
program begins shortly we invite you to
donate to the st louis chess club in
world chess hall of fame
in our efforts to advance the artistic
cultural
and educational benefits of chess
strategy across the board
is moments away thanks for being with us
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility will feature new
ground-level classrooms supporting
players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces
with state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow even greater community
engagement
in the great game of chess as a proud
resident of the central west end
neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the sinkfield cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
thank you for joining us for the 2020
virtual gala
strategy across the board featuring
world champion grand master
gary kasparov our live program begins
shortly
we invite you to donate to the st louis
chess club in world chess hall of fame
in our efforts to advance the artistic
cultural
and educational benefits of chess
strategy across the board
is moments away thanks for being with us
professional golf returns to st louis in
2021
the ascension charity classic presented
by emerson
stars like phil mickelson ernie else jim
furyk and more compete at norwood hills
country
club september 6th through the 12th
tickets clubhouse passes hospitality
suites and pro-am foursomes are on sale
now
all proceeds go to north st louis county
charities visit
ascensioncharityclassic.com or call
314-938-282
pga tour golf is back in the louvre the
ascension
charity classic
welcome to strategy across the board a
virtual gala showcasing the many ways
the st
louis chess club and hall of fame is
promoting chess as an art form
an educational tool our live program
from the st
louis campus starts at the top of the
hour with a special keynote by world
chess
champion grand master gary kasparov
until then
please visit the virtual rooms below for
a look at the broad scope of programs
offered by the st louis chess club and
world chess hall of fame
hello i'm penny pennington i'm the
managing partner
of edward jones and our firm we have a
simple
and important purpose to make a
meaningful difference in the lives of
seven million clients
and their families our goal is to help
them to help you
achieve your most important goals one
way that we deliver on this is to help
our clients have a better
understanding of their finances and
investing
our branch teams see firsthand the
confidence
that can come from a higher level of
financial knowledge
after all the best way to achieve your
goals is to understand how the decisions
that you make today
will make your goals a reality in the
future
that's why we're making tools like this
online
financial fitness site available to you
we recognize that many young people lack
the financial information necessary
to establish or to strengthen your
financial wellness
and we want to help we know from our
research that when you understand the
principles of finance
and investing you're more likely to plan
for the future
and to achieve higher levels of
education
income and career satisfaction
these tools were designed to be easy to
use
interactive and to build financial
resiliency to help you be confident
about your financial decisions
no matter the market or the environment
we also created the site to meet you
where you are
so whether you use it at home or on the
go we hope you find this site engaging
and impactful as you hone your knowledge
and get more financially fit
if there's anything that we can do for
you we have 19
000 financial advisors in all 50 states
and all 10
provinces in canada and we're here to
help you to answer
your financial questions thank you for
the opportunity to serve you
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health and strength it's the sound
of compassion
of open doors where people and machines
are in tune
and miracles occur it's the sound of
personalized healthcare
and active communities it sounds like
life
and it's what you hear when you really
listen
thank you for joining us for the 2020
virtual gala
strategy across the board featuring
world champion grand master
gary kasparov our live program begins
shortly
we invite you to donate to the st louis
chess club in world chess hall of fame
in our efforts to advance the artistic
cultural and
educational benefits of chess strategy
across the board
is moments away thanks for being with us
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world
and plays host to all major tournaments
including the us chess championships
and the sinkfield cup one of the
strongest chess tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills and increased
confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the us and world chess
halls of faith
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess
art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries
and a premier gift shop highlight the
culture history
and creativity behind the game come
visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus
visit stlchestcampus.org
that was an amazing piece of calculation
that easily dominated his rivals when in
game after game the opposition has never
been
as heated as fierce and most elite chess
tournaments
in the world
time and time again chess has proven
that it's a connector
a connector for people no matter your
race
your economic status or the language you
speak the rules are the same for
everyone
my name is lauren stewart director of
development for the st louis chess club
and world chess hall of fame
and welcome to the fourth annual
strategy across the board gala
and though we can't be together in
person tonight we are excited to
celebrate with you virtually
st louis has seen a surge in chess over
the last decade which has been
incredible and not only do we play chess
at the st louis chess club but we played
in parks
all throughout the city of st louis such
as this one
and if you happen to visit one of these
parks you may get the opportunity to
play against one of the 25 grand masters
that have chose to move to st louis and
make a life here
all for the game of chess
many of these grand masters are walking
our very own college campuses
playing for their collegiate chess team
webster university
university of missouri columbia and our
very own st louis university
these rising chest stars are setting the
precedent for all young students
interested in the game of chess
not only does chess encourage strategy
and confidence
but it creates art shapes culture and
has produced some of the best artwork of
all time
the world chess hall of fame is just one
piece of the puzzle
to the cultural offerings in st louis it
too is a connector
binding together art culture history
fashion and music solo artists and local
musicians are given
life-changing opportunities at the world
chess hall of fame and our visitors and
members are able to experience it
firsthand the world trust hall of fame
is the only institution of its kind in
the world
featuring the world's largest chess
piece certified by the guinness book of
world records
normally this place is filled with
students and adults battling over the
board
but like everyone else in 2020 we've had
to make adjustments
due to covet 19 our scholastic chess
initiative
has gone completely virtual on our newly
created scholastic chess portal
a safe alternative for students to log
on each week
secretly build their confidence and play
against their classmates
without the support and the vision of
our founders dr
jeanne karen singfield and rex singfield
chess and st louis just simply wouldn't
be possible
i'd like to thank our presenting
sponsors along with jeannie and racks
edward jones and ascension for their
ongoing support
as non-profit organizations we rely
heavily on the support of the community
we hope you'll feel inspired tonight to
make a gift and help support chess and
st
louis and around the world
now i'd like to introduce to you
somebody who's been incredibly
supportive
of the st louis chess campus and
strategy across the board
he appreciates what chess has done for
students and adults
and he has seen firsthand how chess
impacts somebody's life
he plays on the edward jones corporate
chess league team
he's a general partner with edward jones
and he is the 2020 event chair
for strategy across the board it's my
pleasure to introduce you to
john beckstead
thank you lauren hello and welcome to
strategy across the board
a virtual gala for the saint louis chess
club and the world chess hall of fame
my name is john beckstead and i'm the
event chair for tonight's event
on behalf of edward jones investments we
are thrilled to be one of the presenting
sponsors this evening
a very special thank you to dr jean
karen singfeld
and rex singfeld as well as ascension
our co-presenting sponsors for the event
this is our fourth annual gala and it
does look a little different this year
even though we can't be together in
person we're excited for you to be
joining us tonight from your homes
we have a wonderful program for you that
really showcases
the great things that the st louis chess
campus has done to advance the game of
chess
both here in st louis as well as all
around the globe
i'd like to thank you in advance for
your support tonight and i hope you'll
consider making a gift
to continue to advance the game of chess
now let's get started
i'd like to introduce you to our master
of ceremonies for this evening
mike isaacson mike is in his 10th season
as the artistic director
and executive producer of the muni he's
the third person to hold this position
in the muni's 103 year history
for nearly 25 years mike has been
producing on broadway
in london in many national tours
he's produced 23 broadway shows and is
the recipient of six tony awards
including two for best musical we're so
thankful to have his talents here
tonight to help us
ladies and gentlemen it's my pleasure to
introduce to you
mike isaacson
good evening and we are live here in the
studios of the st
louis chess club on behalf of the st
louis chess club
and world chess hall of fame welcome to
the fourth annual
strategy across the board gala i'm mike
isaacson and i'm
so proud to be your host for tonight's
virtual fundraiser
now you may ask yourself how did a
broadway guy a theater guy
end up hosting a benefit celebrating
chess well i have to tell you
i was so excited when they asked me to
do this i live
and work nearby and for about the last
decade
i have watched in total awe of all the
incredible progress of these two
institutions
the interest in prominence the st louis
chess club and the world chess hall of
fame
have brought to st louis along with
thousands of visitors and so many
incredible talents
well it's just been really exciting and
i'm in awe of it
it's also wonderful to celebrate a game
that embodies and celebrates
the best of who we are chess is the
discipline and power of the mind
chess is a respect for tradition chess
is fierce and honorable competition
chess is a worldwide community and yes
this year's fundraiser looks slightly
different and we sure wish we could all
be together in person
but i want you to know that this amazing
hour we're going to spend together was
created
with exacting safety standards and
precautions
just off the screen here is my mask
there's two other people in the room
they're like 10 yards away
they have done everything to the highest
standards and we need to congratulate
them for making this happen
tonight is going to be a wonderful night
celebrating the game of chess
through education art and culture and i
hope you had a chance to view our
cocktail rooms prior to seven o'clock
if not after the program tonight you'll
be able to click the videos below me
and watch all of the wonderful offerings
both the st louis chess club and the
world chess hall of fame have to offer
today december 1st is giving tuesday a
global generosity movement
unleashing the power of people and
organizations to transform their
communities in the world
and this is the perfect time for you to
support the important work
here at the st louis chess club and
world chess hall of fame
please consider making a donations of 25
or more this evening and don't forget to
check out our amazing auction
which will be open until next tuesday
december 8th
at 5 pm central time if you're tuning in
to our event
site click the items tab in the upper
left corner of your screen
if you're watching via youtube visit
2020satb.givesmart.com
to view the items the cocktail reception
videos or to make a donation
it's a full wonderful program tonight so
let's get started and we're going to
begin with some fun
the st louis chess club is all about
using chess as an educational tool
and that includes players at the college
level you're going to meet
coaches of two university teams two
programs made possible by the chess club
let's take a look
hello i'm grand master alejandro ramirez
i am the coach of saint louis university
thanks to our partnership with the st
louis chess club from back in 2016
we've been able to build an elite chess
team for our school
starting with only four grand masters we
were able to build up the team to now
have 12 scholarship
players and they have represented us in
all parts of the world
from panama all the way to china we are
proud to have an elite
team with us thanks to the generosity of
dr ginny singfield and of course rack
singfield
with us is also the head coach of
mizzou's chess program
christian carrillo thank you alejandro
and uh
welcome everybody at the gala it's an
honor and a privilege to be here with
you
and represent the university of missouri
we are
a new program we partner in 2019
with the saint louis chess club it has
been a very fruitful
partnership and we have grown to have
four grand masters right now on our team
and we are continuing to expand
and uh we have a match on our hands
today between uh two of our freshmen
alejandro who is your player the newest
member of the st
louis university chess team is gabriela
antova
she is a women's international master
hailing from bulgaria she's a multiple
time medalist
out of european youths and she's here to
show
what she's made of and from mizzou we
have uh olia badelka she is a freshman
from
belarus she is actually going to be
playing from
belarus and uh yeah let's start the
games
and off we go off we go with a very
interesting
ready opening i didn't know that you
taught such passive openings christian
um well you know the repertoire
is something that the players come with
and this was part
of uh olia's repertoire but also i
wouldn't say that the red is necessarily
a passive opening it's a very nuanced
opening
detailed if you might say alejandro we
will keep an eye on
our players and the moves they make and
we will be back with you
shortly
st louis is a city known for its vast
array of cultural offerings
and its long-standing support of the
arts including the world chess hall of
fame
the world chess hall of fame is
passionate about educating visitors
and celebrating one of the globe's most
beloved games by exhibiting
world-renowned artists and showcasing
the best artistic talent st
louis has to offer as a matter of fact
i'm standing right now in the first
floor of the world chess hall of fame
in their newest exhibition keith herring
radiant gambit
and it is fantastic you must come visit
and see it
the world chess hall of fame invited
four local artists to create brand new
works all paying homage to herring
including local artist pete eise woliger
take a look at how the world chess hall
of fame ended up in st
louis and the opportunity it provides st
louis artists to be featured
in this internationally recognized
museum
in 1986 the u.s chess federation founded
the chess hall of fame unfortunately in
2008 with the recession the museum had
to close
and that just happened to be the time
where in july of 2008 the st louis chess
club opened up and
immediately all eyes were on st louis
chess they started hosting the us
championships and the women's
championships
and it just kept growing and growing and
growing so the people that had been
involved with the museum in miami
thought that this would be a perfect
location
for this museum which was no longer open
so a 501 c
3 was started the sing fields with their
generosity
provided the seed money to move the
museum to
st louis and it just happened to be a
building across the street from the club
was for sale it was renovated the
contents of the museum moved here
and we started building a museum here in
st louis
the unique thing about the world chess
hall of fame as it is in st
louis is that it's not just a chess hall
of fame we do
all kinds of cultural programming here
we've got monthly music series composer
series
our exhibitions don't just look at the
great players of the game but how chess
is incorporated in every aspect of life
we do shows like chess and fashion chess
and science
chess and space chess and beauty and so
you do not have to be
a expert chess player or a chess
historian
to come here and enjoy the exhibitions
enjoy our programming and learn
something new
we show all different caliber of artists
and we've shown everything from yoko ono
to the great
photojournalist harry benson one thing
that i think is also
so important to do is showcase local
artists
artists need opportunities
to really show the work that they've
been
putting their heart and soul in that
opportunity for artists at the chess
hall of fame who
exhibited here it's priceless
being able to create so freely
and with such a strong team is any
artist's dream
the world chess hall of fame really
created sort of like a
hub of a community of arts based around
the idea and concept of chess i feel as
if
it's brought a community together that
might not otherwise interact
st louis is such a unique city it has so
many
cultural institutions and i think that
we fit so well
into that unique atmosphere here
our attendance has been exploding in the
last couple of years and we are so proud
of that
and in may this year we welcomed our 100
000th visitor
we have people from all over the world
coming to visit
we really are becoming a destination
spot in st
louis because of the vision of the sing
fields and their constant support
and the support of our amazing donors it
gives the staff
so much opportunity to create unique
and amazing programming
whenever you are trying to add something
meaningful to your community it really
takes
an all hands on deck kind of approach
when you really see what the impact of
chess has you see why it is so critical
to have everybody's support
i am so looking forward to the next
chapter of chess and st
louis especially at the hall of fame
with our exhibitions programming
our artistic programming and getting new
people to love the game of chess
good evening and thank you for joining
us my name is nate cohen
me my family and my family business
cohen
architectural woodworking have been long
time partners and supporters
of the st louis chess club and the world
chess hall of fame
we're proud to support the chess campus
and the strategy across the board and
what it represents
spreading the lifelong benefits of the
game of chess
especially in rural communities
throughout the state of missouri
which rings true for us being in st
james
chess has the power to change lives and
transform future generations
as a member of the chess campus young
professionals board
i've seen firsthand how these
organizations have inspired
our communities and i'm excited for
what's to come
i'd like to thank dr jeannie and rex
sinkfield for their vision
and their commitment to chess please
consider making a gift to the chess
campus to advance
scholastic chess programming and art and
culture of the game
i hope you enjoy the rest of the program
the saint louis chess club and the world
chess hall of fame wouldn't exist
it wasn't for co-founders dr jeannie
karen singfeld
and rexingfeld what they have
accomplished for the game of chess here
in st louis is
unprecedented let's take a look at the
amazing journey of rexingfeld
rex singhfield was born in saint louis
after the unexpected death of his father
rex and his younger brother jerry moved
to the saint vincent home for children
in st louis at saint vincent's rex was
cared for by the sisters of christian
charity
he studied hard found ways to make his
peers laugh and succeeded
after graduating from bishop de berg
high school in st louis
rex entered the seminary after three
years
rex made the difficult decision not to
pursue the priesthood
and instead enrolled in st louis
university where he majored in
philosophy and business
rex then moved on to the university of
chicago where he studied business under
nobel prize winners and
american economists eugene fama and
merton miller
rex earned a masters of business
administration and was now an
mba rex went to work for the american
national bank of chicago where he
pioneered a new way of investing index
funds
it was a life-changing discovery
in 1981 together with college classmate
david booth
rexco founded the investment firm
dimensional fund advisors
dimensional's great success allowed rex
to pursue one of his great passions
chess
in 2008 along with wife dr jeannie karen
singfeld
rex opened the st louis chess club and
scholastic center
which has now become the epicenter of
chess in america
rex is active in many civic and cultural
institutions
and with wife dr jeanne continue to
support the community with generous
financial contributions
rec serves on the boards of the missouri
botanical garden missouri history museum
opera theater of st louis st louis art
museum
st louis symphony the contemporary art
museum the saint vincent home for
children
and st louis university i'm proud to
present to you the co-founder
of the st louis chess club and the world
chess hall of fame
rex singfeld
good evening and welcome to our annual
strategy across the board gala
i'm sorry that we can't all be here
tonight in person
enjoying the dinner and the program
together but it's given us an
opportunity to try new things
and to reach the chess fans and
educators across the globe
i want to thank lauren ryan and the
staff for creating this gala
and randy and the team at spectrum
studios for powering this gala tonight
and as always we want to thank joy and
her staff
for overseeing this wonderful event this
year has been challenging for all of us
but we see this as an opportunity for
everyone to reset
and realize what's important to all of
us personally
as you know i have a passion for chess
many people wonder why and i have
personally seen the transformation of
what the chess club
has done with students and the impact
the game has had on them
both inside and outside of the classroom
we're grateful for all of you being here
and we encourage all of you to make a
donation tonight
to help achieve our fundraising goals
because it's your efforts
to make all of this possible our
fundraising goals support our
programming in st
louis and beyond now i would like to
introduce a short video
that focuses on the mission of the chess
club and how we are impacting the lives
of the saint louis community
the mission of the st louis chess club
is three-fold we hold major events to
spotlight the top players both
nationally and internationally
we run a chess club which is a great
community center that's open to the
public seven days a week
and most importantly we focus on st
louis area schools where we teach
chess to more than 100 classrooms each
school year
chess helps students understand planning
metacognition which is thinking about
their thinking
and it also helps them to understand
strategy overall
as far as thinking three or four or five
steps ahead
the kids have been very excited and
they've shown enthusiasm
about learning the game and teaching it
to their peers as well
i've been surprised how passionate they
are about it and they're able to
comprehend chess at such a very young
age
studies show the children who play chess
and play it actively
their reading scores improve by a grade
level
because of the concentration because of
the focus of chess
they are able to tune out a lot of
distractions in their academics
and focus on the subject at hand
the kids care they're asking is the
community partner still coming are we
still going to have chess today they're
really excited to see i get to go to the
tournament
and they're eager to share all of that
you can see their confidence in it
we've seen students master doing
multi-step moves and chess
and we see that transfer over into
multi-step equations in mathematics
all because of the introduction of chess
into our schools
the chess cops program puts us in a
situation
for a dialogue for a competition that we
otherwise would not have
and the conversation that may or may not
occur at the board
might have to do with chess it might
have to do with things going on at home
might have to do with a basketball game
and that conversation can open up a lot
of doors this gives
kids a chance to see us in a far
different light than out on the street
where we may be in a more formal and
enforcement capacity
they get to see that we're we're just
like anybody else
sharing a love for chess one of the most
important things that i feel as a parent
and as an adult is to teach
young minds to strategically problem
solve
and chess is an absolute phenomenal way
for them
to hone in on that skill set it helps
them with their critical thinking
they learn instead of planning one or
two steps ahead that you got to plan a
lot further
this is a type of program you can't just
measure this with numbers
you'll never be able to quantify the
significance of what's happening
over those chess boards when they're
back out in the community they can
honestly
plan far enough in advance to have
success
the st louis chess club would like to
see chess in every classroom
they'd like to see every student in the
st louis area receive chess
programming not to make grandmasters out
of these students but more importantly
to teach the life lessons that the game
of chess can instill
we encourage any school district and all
other partners to get engaged because
our children need these type of
activities now
over the years we have had the great
fortune to work very closely
with legendary world champion gary
kasparov
and his guidance and his insight and
leadership have helped us
do a lot of wonderful things and at this
time i would like to introduce him
and a video of the great grand master
gary castrof
hello everyone this is gary kasparov
speaking from croatia
i'm sorry we cannot all be together in
saint louis
which has become a second home to me
actually i'm sorry i cannot
be anywhere these days i usually spend
hundreds of hours on airplane each year
however and i don't really miss that
part
but a few more months of lockdown and
i'll probably be
feeling nostalgic about the airport
security line
saint louis became a second home to me
because it has become
a first home to my beloved game of chess
thanks to rex and ginny sinfield
missouri has become the epicenter
of a chess renaissance in the united
states
america is bringing home gold medals in
every age group
and challenging for the world
championship for the first time since
bobby fischer
best of all chess is being treated with
a new level of respect that reminds me
of the soviet union
thankfully nothing else here does
and as is always the case american
leadership
matters in the world and he said louis
had impressive ripple effects across the
globe with
more elite events than ever even more
importantly
chess is booming on the grassroots level
across the country school programs use
tournaments
chess is making great progress this is
no small thing
and not just about bringing home or gold
medals
as rex and i believe and as many studies
show chess is a powerful tool
for education with many benefits for
kids
it's much more than math as many still
as you
chess develops critical thinking skills
and creative problem solving
it allows for healthy competition
between anyone at any age
and while i might be a little bit biased
chess develops character and discipline
if you want to win
you must prepare control your emotions
and learn to accept and understand your
failures
most of all chess is fun
the game has survived and thrived for
hundreds of years
and now competes successfully with the
internet and video games
when i was a kid growing up on the
soviet union
there wasn't much else to do but today
kids have a million distractions
and yet chess still adapts and expands
in the ussr chess was taken quite
seriously
as a hobby and a sport but the game
also has a long positive history in the
united states
even in saint louis one of the host
cities of the very first official world
chess championship in 1886
america's attraction to chess
has stayed alive all the time
especially in pop culture hollywood
has long been fascinated by chess as a
symbol of logic and intelligence
a couple of my favorites i'm free bogart
in casablanca
and of course a scene from james bond
from russia with love
even aliens play chess in the original
star trek series
the emotional human captain kirk often
defeated
the super logical vulcan mr spock moving
into the 21st century
young wizards play chess at hogwarts in
harry potter
teenage vampires play in the twilight
series
it's always pleasant to see chess and
chess players portrayed
in positive light there's still some
stereotypes
about players that the game can make you
crazy
or that is only for super intelligent
nerds
i've always been happy to participate in
any
projects that can help refute
these all cliches last year
one such opportunity came up
and i had to accept if you haven't
watched the queen's gambit on netflix
yet
apparently you are one of the few a
series about a female chess prodigy
has become the number one netflix show
in the us
and the world amazing based on the 1983
novel by walter tevis
it's a fictional coming-of-age story
about a kentucky orphan
named best hormone who becomes a chess
star
while struggling with substance
addictions in the 60s
when the show's creator scott frank
contacted me about being involved
i couldn't say no he first tried to get
me to play
best soviet rival while champion vasily
borgo
who faces her in the dramatic climax of
the show
don't worry no spoilers but i didn't
think i
could invest so much time and instead
offered my services
as a consultant i created the key chess
games
seen in the show in most cases
modifying actual grandmaster games in
ways to fit
the descriptions in the book i also
helped make sure
the chest atmosphere was realistic of
course
there have to be some theatrical license
but it is as
real as anything you will see from
hollywood
i also made some contributions about the
how the soviets acted including the kgb
guys who were always around even when i
was playing
two decades after bess harmon's
fictional story
takes place there are already signs
that the success of the queen's gambit
is
fueling a new chess boom google searches
for learning to play chess
have gone way up and some days it feels
like
most of my social media feed is full of
compliments and questions about the
series
i don't know how many people will
actually continue with this new interest
but having a brilliant show about chess
be number one
must be better than the last netflix
show that was number one
that one was about a tiger king not a
chess king
much of my time these days is dedicated
to
lecturing about what i call the human
machine
relationship i speak on it from personal
experience
some of you may recall that i played two
matches against an ibm
super computer d blue in 1996 and in
1997.
yes there were two matches nobody
remembers that i won the first one
oh well after that
i figured if you can beat them join them
the writing was on the wall today you
can play
a free app on your phones that is
stronger than the blue
a good example of how fast technology
moves
the blue wasn't intelligent really
even though it considered a landmark in
artificial intelligence
it was as intelligent as your alarm
clock
although losing to a 10 million dollar
alarm clock
didn't make me feel any better for me
life went on for deep blue wow
this picture is a real place a sushi
restaurant in terminal 5
at jfk airport in new york city i have
to pass it all the time i love sushi
but i can't eat there all jokes aside
our future will be defined but how well
we adapt
to working with our increasingly
intelligent machines
it's about teamwork not competition it's
human plus machine not
humans against machine and i will
continue to take over more and more road
work
allowing us to be more creative i like
to say that we're not being replaced
we are being promoted this is why i
prefer to call ai augmented intelligence
not artificial it makes us smarter the
way
telescope enhances our vision and in
both cases
we have to know how to point it in the
right direction
hollywood has some insight into this as
well
this might seem like a bad example to
tell
people not to be afraid of intelligent
machines
the original movie came out in 1984 and
was the story of
a rock ai called
skynet it became self-aware and decided
to try to
wipe out humanity except why would
an intelligent ai do this nobody ever
explains that part
more importantly the second and the
third terminator movies
are great examples of human plus machine
defeating a superior machine the old
t800 model played by arnold
schwarzenegger
teams up first with sarah connor
and later with her teenage son to defeat
the far more advanced
terminator models they cannot match
their power
but they use the power they have more
creatively
and they adapt better and faster than
the machines
and that photo of me and arnold isn't
cgi
even terminators play chess if not quite
well as
the blue i'm sure you understand why i
offered him a draw
quite early chess has been a great
laboratory
for our machines and our human minds as
well
and now we bring these threads together
kids today have all the knowledge
in the world at their fingerprints they
will grow up with
virtual assistants surrounded by
algorithms the potential power is
remarkable
especially if you compare to what we
grew up with
we're all worried about our kids having
too much screen time right
but think about what they can do with
those screens
anything limitless information
more computing power in their pockets
than all of nasa
when america landed on the moon in 1969
the issue is one not of resources but of
judgment
of critical thinking of creativity of
collaboration
these are the things we must develop in
our kids
to thrive in the age of intelligent
machines
we don't really need to teach them
what and when anymore but
how and why this to no surprise
is where we come back to chess back to
missouri
and back to the san luis chess club
because those are all things that chess
can teach
us and can teach our children
with every move we make a decision with
every response
we learn the consequences of our actions
from every game we see our strengths and
weaknesses
and our own decision making style on the
64
squares few young players will become
chess masters
but chess will help every one of them
become masters of themselves
masters of their own minds it will also
provide a lifetime of joy and
competition
as much for kids growing up in san luis
today as for me
growing up in baku 50 years ago
this is why i'm always happy to support
the saint louis chess club
and i hope you will be as well
thank you
wow thank you for those inspiring words
gary
what you have done and what are you
doing for chess all across the globe is
truly making a difference i had no idea
you were so involved with the queen's
gambit and
if you're watching and you haven't
watched it yet when we're done here
check it out it's on netflix it's truly
the best thing of the year
now if like me you were inspired by
gary's words
i encourage you to make a donation now
to support the st louis chess campuses
scholastic chess
programs and further chess education
through the lens of art history and
culture
no donation is too small and we truly
appreciate your support
and what would any good fundraiser be
without an auction we have a great
auction items for you just
waiting for your bid bit it up bit it up
let's take a look at them
the 2020 strategy across the board
auction items are
live the auction starts now and ends in
one week on december 8th at 5 p.m
central standard time bid now on some
incredible items
highlights this year range from
autographed chessboards from the world's
greatest chess players to an amazing
observer experience at the 2021 pga
champions tour
don't miss out on the exclusive luxury
chess sets from the house of staunton
pearling london and american chess
equipment all the proceeds from the
auction go to support the mission and
wonderful work of both the saint louis
chess club and the world chess hall of
fame
the auction is going on right now so if
you're tuning in to our event
site click the items tab in the upper
left corner of your screen
if you're watching on youtube visit
2020satb.givesmart.com
to see the items the cocktail reception
videos or to make a donation
remember make a donation have i been
clear make a donation
all right let's check in on the
collegiate challenge and have some more
fun how is it going coaches
our game is well underway it's an
exciting moment let's check in on the
action
christian what do you see on the board a
very interesting middle game alejandro
uh the the opening phase was a bit
slower but right now things are indeed
heating up
and as we can see black has those uh two
pawns
close to the center the c5 and the d5
pawns but
they're called hanging pawns but right
now they're going to be under attack the
knight on a4 is attacking the pawn on c5
the bishop g2 is nicely placed
on the long diagonal to attack the pawn
on d5 so
this is going to be a battle between the
dynamic play of black
behind those pawns and the strategic
play of white
with a better structure against those
spawns we're going to see
uh who is going to come out ahead it's a
very dynamic position but i have to say
as a positional player i
do like the way that your player is
handling this structure so far let's see
if uh gabriella can show us exactly what
her dynamism is in this position because
it's starting to be very sharp for her
you can see that white has
already immediate threats of for example
taking this knight on f6 and weakening
that position of the c5 pawn something
that she has to be worried about
right on this moment and the time
management christian
what's going on and specifically for
that reason alejandro i think you
should uh black that is has to play the
move d4 and i think that was played
already on the board we're getting some
new moves
it seems like um we had
transmission cut off for just a second
there but we see the time management is
actually not that bad
for your player it seemed at that point
that your player was falling behind
but in fact she is ahead on time so
this is still a very complex middle game
and alejandro shall we come back to this
a little bit later let's do it let's
wait for
more developments and we'll be right
back
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st
louis slu attracts students and
professors from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the st louis
chess club to start
a top-tier collegiate chess team on the
very first year of the teen's inception
slu obtained second best university at
the pan-american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose greater good st louis
university
the pro-chess league is an online chess
competition with teams that span
worldwide this season the st louis
archbishops won the league championship
for an incredible third time in four
years undefeated in their regular season
st louis beat india china and armenia
to cement the archbishops as a true
chess dynasty
we salute this year's all-star team
fabiano caruana
wesley so linear dominguez
and jeffrey zhang
i'm so excited to introduce this next
segment because it's really hits home
and is personal
because from where i'm standing right
now i live actually just one block away
and this is how i became first aware of
the chess club and the st
louis chess hall of fame because if you
live in st
louis you've seen the incredible energy
that this institution has created
over the last 12 years it is so exciting
and so dynamic
and we're so grateful and because of
what's been done here
st louis wants more chess it wants more
chess in schools
more community collaborations more chess
exhibitions
and all of that has culminated in this
room i'm standing in right now which is
the middle of the renovation
to keep up with this overwhelming demand
the saint louis club is thrilled to
welcome
everyone to its newly expanded
facilities during the spring of 2021.
let's take a look
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital
and preeminent global destination for
lovers of the sport
we look forward to seeing you in our new
space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the sinkfield cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
there are many people in corporations to
thank for their continuing support for
all that the st louis
chess club and the world chess hall of
fame have to offer
let's take a moment to share with you a
list of our devoted sponsors
these are the names that make it all
possible
so
professional golf returns to saint louis
in 2021
the ascension charity classic presented
by emerson
stars like phil mickelson ernie else jim
furyk and more compete at norwood hills
country club september 6th through the
12th
tickets clubhouse passes hospitality
suites and pro-am foursomes are on sale
now
all proceeds go to north st louis county
charities visit
ascensioncharityclassic.com or call
314-938-2828
pga tour golf is back in the lou the
ascension charity classic
okay one last time let's go back to our
collegiate challenge
coaches take it away
where are the last seconds of this game
even though the players have a two
second increment that means they get two
seconds added every time they make a
move
you can see that gabrielle is down to
only four seconds she's surviving
on that increment christian your player
has an extra pawn
down to four seconds down a pawn i like
the chances of my player
this one is looking good for white at
the same time
gabriella still has that very very
dangerous d-pawn
that's definitely going to go down the
board so this is still a close call guys
oh yeah and i can see that she's
completely reliant on
that deep queen check that hurts
going for uh for a ride it is but you
can see your player is going down in
seconds and it's just such a sharp game
no queen d3 was an
ugly check to allow the king is in
serious danger now on
h6 what now though she still has to find
the final blow and that is knight f3
knight to e5 i like this maneuver knight
to e5 put the knight in the center
g4 g5 g4 g5 she has to go for g4 g5 she
was afraid of rook takes c5
has she run out of time no she's not
running kings of g5
it's going places but i think oh no that
g5 is really gonna seal the deal
wins a piece and i think the game i
don't think you can save that king on h6
anymore
and that's a win for a white uh
alejandro what a game
these players these freshmen at our
universities have been putting on a show
and once again i want to take this time
to uh thank
everybody that's making our collegiate
programs possible
and of course there is st louis chess
club uh under the patronage of uh
dr jeanne and rex singfield who have
been amazing and they are supporting
chess
from the foundation now from the
scholastic level all the way to the
collegiate level and then if you're good
enough
all the way to the us championship level
so thank you
absolutely without your help this
program simply wouldn't be possible and
we hope to make you proud representing
slu and mizzou at many different events
not just
in america but around the world
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri
is steeped in tradition the recently
founded mizzou chess program
is a partnership between the university
of missouri and the st
louis chess club collegiate jess has
been experiencing a meteoric
rise at the national level through its
tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar
by bringing our institutions ethos of
respect
responsibility discovery and excellence
to the chessboard
now it's time for you to meet the first
of two
very special guests tanita ottawame is
10 years old
and a chess champion he learned to play
chess while living in a homeless shelter
in manhattan
we met tani just after he won the k-3
new york state chess championship in
2019.
he spent some time with us here at the
chess club and to say the least
left an impression at 10 years old tony
is an
author among other things and he is well
on his way to conquering the world of
chess
we believe he will make an impression on
you just like he did on us
i think chess is really important for
students it helps them be smarter
it helps with math things like that but
it just helps them personally in their
life
and things like that so i'm really
excited to have a book come out about my
story
and my family's story in the book it's
basically the story and
from nigeria and a big big
um from a small small
family to now over the whole world
by the way this is my book so my life
has definitely changed in 2020 a lot
it's been very very tough i mean to
covet
and i didn't i didn't i don't i don't
get to play so much
tournaments it's it's not the best but
i always know god is doing something so
i'm just practicing at home playing
online watching account and like stuff
like that and my
goal for next year is to become
an international master or even a
grandmaster
youngest grandmaster advice i would give
someone
that's like starting to play the game
the advice i would give them is how to
move the pieces
and then general strategies basically
they need a lot of hard work because
hard work beats talent if talent doesn't
have hard work
now as i mentioned earlier today is
tuesday december 1st
giving tuesday as it's known around the
world and it's the perfect time for you
to help
us continue the important work of the st
louis chess club and the world chess
hall of fame
ready for this to date we have raised
over 175 thousand dollars on our way to
our goal
of 300 000 dollars we need your donation
right now and we're asking for 25 or
more
to push us over the top and our auction
is also going on
right now and remains open through next
tuesday december 8th
at 5 p.m so please put in your bed soon
have your neighbor outbid you and then
you outbid them
now if you're tuning in to our event
site click the items tab in the upper
left corner of your screen
if you're watching via youtube visit
2020satb
to view the items the cocktail reception
or to make a donation
and now tonight's second very special
guest
baseball's mike matheny is a longtime
friend of the singfelds
and the st louis chess club mike spent
13 years as a catcher in the major
leagues
managed the saint louis cardinals and
now manages the kansas city royals
mike is a tremendous supporter of chess
in st
louis
this has been i always look forward to
for a number of reasons
one the people continue to meet
incredible people involved
in chess and the st louis area and
to just watch how the st louis
area has become such a make mega spot
for
the world of chess and i know that's due
to a lot of effort
just want to thank you for what you've
done and also i want to
just to help you hear it again that what
what we're doing and what
the chess club and the hall of fame are
doing for
our area it's making a difference i'm
always
inspired by people who use their
platform
for good and to do something for others
and
rex and dr jeannie along with so many
donors
for so many years now have have really
built this to a spot where it's making a
huge impact
and not just for people who love the
game of chess but for those who've never
even heard about it are being introduced
the numbers of kids that are being
involved the involvement that we have
with some of the local police and and
how that's starting to build some
bridges and starting to just open
people's eyes
uh to the good that can be done in our
community and bringing good out of
people themselves and so
for me whenever we can get outside of
ourselves and start to
to help other people and different
causes and use whatever it is that we
love
like the game of chess to promote our
community
to promote uh well-being promote
education
all of those are a win for us
individually and for others that
some of them we never even know so thank
you for your generosity you're making a
huge impact
on this community you're making a huge
impact in people's lives
and when we go about life that way you
just can't go wrong so thank you again
so there you have it we have come to the
end of our evening and we are so
grateful to you for spending this time
with us
uh our final gift is you are not going
to have to watch me place
chess because trust me that would be
painful for all involved
for those of you who have made a gift
tonight we thank you for your generosity
and for your support of chess
it means so much to us now if you're
still considering an auction item as a
holiday gift and there's so many great
things please look at them
the auction will remain open until
tuesday december 8th
at 5 p.m central time so please please
please go check that out
and finally we want to thank our
founders and presenting sponsors
dr jeannie karen singfeld rex singfeld
edward jones and ascension
they made this evening possible they've
made so much happen for this community
and we're
truly truly grateful to them so thank
you
we hope you had a great night we're so
grateful to everybody behind the scenes
who made this happen in these
challenging times
and please stay safe have a happy
holiday
you